japan is a nation in mourning after the
assassination of its former leader
shinzo abe on friday
but for its governing liberal democratic
party a glimmer of good news after
sunday's upper house elections
the ldp has been the dominant party
since the end of the second world war
and had a high approval rating going
into the vote
abe was a member of the lower house and
still wielded considerable influence as
head of the ldp's largest faction
analysts say the results will help prime
minister kishida consolidate power
you know the biggest threat to his
position has been shinzo abe so the fact
that abe was killed a couple of days ago
actually
is another thing that may stabilize his
regime in a strange way
the strong election showing will give
him a chance to increase military
spending
revising japan's pacifist constitution
one of abe's unfulfilled ambitions is
also likely to be on the cards
although analysts say amending the
constitution will not be an easy process
[Music]
it is still unclear how to amend the
constitution and which parts of it need
to be amended
even in amongst those in support of
constitution amendment opinions vary a
lot
there can't be a quick change of the
constitution even any block getting
two-thirds of the seats can't do it
the japanese people will vote on it and
it is hard to pass
meanwhile the suspect in abe's
assassination has been handed over to
prosecutors in nara where he will likely
be detained and questioned before being
charged
police have acknowledged there were
security flaws in friday's attack and
have promised a thorough investigation
florence louis al jazeera